this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's Thursday the 13th of
the month the joint is brought to you by
DraftKings we got a great game tonight
we got Chicago versus Washington it's
tremendous it's the Amazon whatever it
is prime [__] football game on
Thursday nights at everyone can boost
their winnings with DraftKings stepped
up same game parlays the NFL action is
in full swing [__] and DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
part of the NFL would take in touchdowns
big plays with biting [__] new
customers can bet five dollars on any
NFL team to win and get 200 and free
bets if they do everyone can boost their
winnings with DraftKings stepped up same
game parlays like I said tonight we got
Chicago against Washington
I may go with a total tonight but if I
do go with a parlay
I like Chicago tonight how's that one
for you [__] to make things even
sweeter you could throw down a step
stepped up same game Paul Asian the more
legs you had the more money money you
win download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app now use promo code Joey to get 200
and free bets if your team wins just
plays five dollars to bet on any
football team that's coach Joey only at
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting part in the NFL we got college
football we got baseball playoffs and we
got preseason NBA and [__] hockey and
you're still sitting there scratching
your head and [__] fantasy is an
all-time [__] high download the
DraftKings fantasy app at the code Joey
and let's make some [__] money
remember minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details download the fantasy app
download the Sportsbook app and let's
get this party started the joint is also
brought to you by blue chew there's
nothing more scarier than not being able
to perform buchu is here to make sure
your dick is all treat and no tricks
blue shoe is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
Vialis and seat Cialis and Viagra but
are the chewable tablets all at a
fraction of the cost take the many time
and be ready whenever the opportunity
Rises whenever you're bump into a pigeon
let me tell you something you can take
these on empty stomach they're
tremendous and the process is simple
sign up at bluetube.com consult with a
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved voila you'll receive
your prescription within days the best
part it's all done online nobody knows
nothing no doctor's office no Pharmacy
[__] them all Bluetooth tablets are made
in the USFA a USA and shipped in a
discreet package the mailman won't know
nothing your grandmother won't know it's
a perfect combination you can benefit
from extra confidence when it's time to
get down and Bluetooth can help try
Bluetooth free
what are you talking about I'm talking
about free try this take the deal use
promo code Joey and just pay five
dollars for shipping so change your
[__] life plus they'll call you
Captain hard on Bluetooth with code Joey
for your first month visit bluetooth.com
for more important safety information
thanks Bluetooth for sponsoring The
Joint let's get this party started my
girl Tara is here today
thank you
welcome to Uncle Joey's Joy
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey on a Thursday morning with my
girl Tara looking good what's happening
thank you what's happening what's
happening you know me dog I know you
what's your last name how do I say oh
canis Tracy okay we'll just leave it
Tara jokes
see let's see
uh what's going on nothing thank you
welcome me to the gym thank you for
having me you have a beautiful home
thank you beautiful wife thank you he's
all right he's good looking dude Mike
I'm happy you made it down here thank
you no [__] please when Vinnie when
uh dino told me you want to come on it
was like any time she's family you know
what's going on in your world what's
going on I'm recording an album on
Saturday you excited I am I am I did a
compilation one before this and now
what's the compilation album so there's
a few other Comics okay and we did one
and that one went well okay and I said
in time for my hour how do you feel
about you I feel good I feel like I want
to I want to get it done and put it to
bed and this is audio audio visual it's
gonna be audio and visual but yeah
that's such a [__] great place and I
love Dino to death oh my God it's my
jersey home you know but they had some
problems this week well not problems
they just had a situation with some
[__]
you know some white trash dude [__]
uh chocolate beer can Chuck the beer can
at some people and I I mean I saw your
picture and I retweeted yesterday but
the first thing I thought about I was
gonna put like bring helmets oh yeah
catches meant rather catch a face mask
but you're trying to do a special you
don't wanna
but it's always something that's been in
the back of your mind like for 20 years
I always thought about what would stop
somebody from throwing something at you
attacking you on stage and all of a
sudden in 2022 it's starting uh you know
this is this is real now that girl if
she would have hit got hit with that be
a can it would have not been a good
[__] night I heard how hard it was
when you hit that wall and I think he
threw it to miss her on purpose maybe I
hope he didn't throw the candy
will be there yeah no he was drunk he
was [__] drunk the dude was you know
and
you know there's a couple ways you can
attack this but there's no other ways
there's no reason why you should be
throwing anywhere anything anything it's
only anything anywhere
you know and I've always said it I I've
said that listen people I did not know
this I did not know that they just
implemented a fine on cruise ships
it's a five and off fine if you act the
wrong way they helicopter you off and
you got to pay all that [__] out of your
own [__] pocket could you imagine
they helicopter people off all the time
the helicopter Comics off if you go on
one of those [__] Bahamas oh yeah or
one of those places and you're not
supposed to [__] curse and you Cur
and they tell you like it's in the
country oh if you don't have a clean set
no and you go up to like there's a lot
of guys I.E like me that would do that
like you could you got to work clean
they're gonna hurt I don't think anybody
thinks you're working clean
maybe in the valley you have 30 minutes
and you were trying to feature they're
like oh yeah you're gonna work clean
you're like yeah yeah I work clean
you're not going to work clean you go up
there you [__] around you say [__] they
stop the show
they go to your room and clean it out
for you you're not even allowed to go
back to your room and they helicopter
you the [__] out
you can't you can't you can't if you're
a comic you can't sleep in any of the
paint like the cruise guests like you
can get kicked off they have like real
strict rules if you're on one of those
crucial you're not on vacation you're no
you're an employee no no and if you're a
comic you can you drink but you can't
have a certain amount of alcohol in your
system like I have a dear friend that
does cruise ships there was a fight
he was there he tried to break him up
when the ship police came they [__]
breathalyzed everybody they fired
he had nothing to do with the fight
welcome to corporate comedy in America
a lot nicer when you're like I'm
cruising around telling jokes sounds a
lot I've never really considered a
cruise ship or yeah like I've never
considered it not because I'm A pompous
[__] or anything like that because
that's not to me that's not what
stand-up was intended for I don't know
and even then yeah music on the ship you
know yeah when the ship is going down
like remember yeah they're playing the
violin as the ship was going down keep
playing [__] listen I'm swimming
I'm not [__] playing
so and I can't imagine how it feels for
a woman see that happened to a woman the
other day
oh they can and that that's where my
[__] [__] stops like right there like
I could see a guy saying something with
you a guy but a girl get you a bottle at
a non-assuming white sweet girl
she handled it like a boss
I heard she drank it like I wish I I'm
the the
paranoid you know like hypochondriac of
me would be scared to touch a germ but
like the way she just took she said she
had like one Split Second and she was
like you gotta drink this and she's
gonna go on Kimball now yeah I think so
he retweeted good for her yeah God
[__] bless her what made you as
pretty as you are get into this [__]
terrible [__] career you know
everybody thinks or did you get into it
because you enjoyed staying it was stand
up for me and it was stand up for me
probably from really early on before I
even knew like like if we were talking
earlier and you know in your living room
like I was always drawn to Comedy like
my Aunt would say as little like as two
years old I'd be watching Johnny Carson
and The Honeymooners and The Carol
Burnett Show and I Love Lucy like not
stand up necessarily but comedy I was I
always loved comedy Saturday Night Live
like as a kid that's what I was watching
you know it wasn't so much cartoons I
was watching these characters on TV
and then uh I always wanted to do it but
you know you
you think you can't or you rationalize
like oh I can't make a living I have to
do this or I have to pay bills or I have
to so I I held I held off doing it
for quite a while and then uh the show
The Last Comic Standing came out
and I was psyched the first season oh my
God I watched every episode I loved
watching people do their thing I loved
it oh my God I loved it and then I
couldn't wait for the next season and
then by the time that next season came
out I said I couldn't watch it anymore
it was bothering me it was like making
me upset
and that's not me like I Champion
everyone you want to make boxes and sell
them on the corner and you want to
bedazzle a cane and sell my friends want
to have babies and get married I
celebrate it to watch people do their
thing and do and and it bother me I knew
that it was because I was suppressing
doing it
and I was like okay this isn't me so now
what am I gonna do because now I'm
I'm not even enjoying it am I enjoying
watching other people do it
so I put my big girl pants on
and uh I went and I started what was the
first place you performed the producers
Club I was in like an off Off-Broadway
sketch comedy play and the producer said
you want to do it go out every night and
warm up the crowd you know write your
five minutes and go warm up and like the
first few nights they'd be like pushing
me on stage and I'd be like no no no
this was a mistake and then by the end
of the run of the show I was like is it
my time am I going up when are we
starting I wanna you get that you know
get those first few laughs and you're
like this is it whatever this is this is
it like the other day somebody goes well
what's the end game I go the end game's
always going to be being on that stage
what you get from it obviously you know
it's a platform for other things but for
me it's it's always going to be stand up
because that's what I really feel like
that's what it is you said something
that really opened up something for me
you know
we were talking about uh Eleanor on
Monday uh people were around comedy I
think when you're a kid
and you're around it like I was a fan of
Carol Burnett The Tonight Show me too
[__] Hee Haw it was a big Hee Haw guy
that [__] made me laugh as a kid but you
know I wonder where all this Mech like I
loved uh just the [__] English porno
guy you know Benny Hill that yeah
I love Betty Hill he always did creepy
things like I love you know but it's so
weird we were
I don't know you watch all this TV like
I wonder the people who came from the
Sinai live era I wonder what Comics came
out from the sign that live you know and
just different things that we watched to
build your sense of humor as you're
growing up and you don't even know it
right right I knew what I liked what I
didn't I knew what Comics I knew what I
was drawn to like I don't even do the
comedy of Carol Burnett her physicality
though all that those things about her I
was like this I didn't know what it was
I was four or five watching you know I
knew my grandmother was laughing and she
never left so I knew something was I
wanted to do whatever they were doing I
just didn't know you know one of the
biggest surprises I got when I come back
to New Jersey two years ago
was I came back knowing that The
Honeymooners were on as stupid as it is
I kept I came here thinking that the
honeymoons were on at 11 o'clock every
night
boy was I a surprise I get Seinfeld
bumped him you know it's like Seinfeld
and creepy [__] shows on Channel 11.
but then I realized they would come out
on midnight and the first time I watched
it with my daughter I remember we
watched it downstairs and almost let's
watch The Honeymooners it was the one
about the Mambo when he learns how to do
the Mambo and [__]
and I got to tell you guys a revealing
thing I've never told nobody it's not
theft it's not theft because I I
struggled with this that episode I was
watching I'm like
I think I stole a lot of Jackie
Gleason's body like it's important too
like Norton is a [__] Champion comic
like Champion the timing they both had
but when I watched that Honeymooners and
I'm in the you know my daughter and I'm
crying and I'm laughing at the same
every time a Honeymooners episode comes
on I Cry
at some point when I laugh I cry because
I cannot believe that this still makes
me laugh yeah the time I was in the
[__] fifth grade I was 10. now I'm 59
I'm still [__] laughing at the same
stupid jokes and somewhere in that
laughter I cried because last time I
used to watch these my mother was alive
there were so many things Nostalgia
throughout all that I did see a lot of
this [__] I did on stage in Jackie
Gleason and I'm not saying I stole it
from him right okay
you're influenced it's somebody watching
somebody over and over and when you said
it I wondered like if the guy who you
know when you watch Seinfeld you watch
Kramer like Art Carney was the first of
that
come out like he came out of the gate
and before you laughed and you when you
watched the shows people are laughing
before he speaks his first word because
he's walking in he's looking at a wall
he's doing this he's turning his
physicality you already know he's funny
he's funny before he says a line
the second wave of Comedy came in my
life and that was Sanford and Son hmm
and Chico and the Man and you know I was
never a big sign of that live guy it's
just did not work for me I would go home
and go what is all the [__] yelling
and screaming about this is not this
good to me you know I just didn't so I
always went when I watched that and let
me know maybe I didn't like clean comedy
I like dirty comedy so I started
listening more to Prior so my world it's
like prior leasing you know it's uh and
you see that years later not that you
should when we start doing comedy we
emulate someone oh at home who did you
emulate what did you think I used to go
say I can never say I've emulated him
but I used to study because I took it
like I had to learn I took it like this
is just the this is the education I was
going to comedy clubs to learn from me I
tracked Colin Quinn like and mind you
I'm never I mean I don't do that comedy
I'm I like to think I'm of above average
intelligence but um no Colin Quinn's on
another level sites and but he was New
York which I can't hide my accent he's
New York and he's smart and his
mannerisms and the way he can I used to
go watch him you're gonna learn even if
it's not what you're doing this is and I
would go wherever he was you know to
watch him and and do things so that for
me I think was my biggest and when I
first came out Amy Schumer was for was
when she first hit the mark where you
saw a really strong you know female New
York female presence on the scene even
if again that wasn't what I wanted
wanted to do or that was my voice it was
still something to learn
I worked at a comedy club I worked on a
like a d room it's called Whitson Aurora
Colorado before I stand up before you
just stand up yeah no I got the job I
took a stand-up course three weeks
twenty thirty three dollars Jeff arms
great University Colorado in the last
class he pulled me aside and he goes I
think you have
if you want to do this I could see you
doing it I go I'm not ready to get on
stage and he goes okay he goes I want
you around it he goes I want you to call
this guy and go down there and that's
what I did the next day I went there
applied and two days later they called
and [__] I worked there from January
of 91 until I got the balls to get on
stage in July of 91.
six months and I got promoted like three
times in those six months by the time I
got on stage I was already a bar back
I was the sound guy and I was the door
guy I was security [__] craziness I
had to do all those jobs but when I was
bar mapping I would watch the comics
that's it just watch watch I think one
of the best jobs in America today if you
really want to do stand up
just move telling go to The Comedy Store
and tell them you want to be a doorman
whether you're a white black green a
woman whatever the [__] you are they're
famous for having seven like the door
people would get spots like that's their
their known for that yeah
right that's being around it you're at
the University of Comedy you're at
[__] Princeton University to learn
comedy it's always great when people get
there and they complain I never
complained I said one thing one time
when I got there I said I wish my spots
were a little earlier I keep getting
these one o'clock spots and some kids
said if you don't want it I'll take it
put the sign up on the wall that you
don't want your one o'clock spot see how
many people take it and that made a lot
of sense yeah you can never complain I
never complained about people bumping me
I never this [__] did [__] it was a
university and I knew that I knew I was
here for four years shut the [__] up I
didn't think I would last for four years
I figured I'd get into a fist fight or
something before that and I get thrown
out no I wanted something more than
three years yeah
and uh it's so crazy like I actually
went in there and I was long listen I
worked the door at the store a lot of
people don't know towards the end
towards them in the middle I remember
going to her and going dog I can't live
on the 25 hosting job and she goes well
why don't you work that dog that's
another 25 I'm like wow double my income
okay 50 raise so I would work the door
until I hosted she gave me a special
spot because I won't tell nobody you
don't tell them all right I would host
then I would go back to work in the door
but by that point I'd get somebody go
hey come here what are you doing right
now nothing you want to host the rest of
the show yeah you're the host and get
security so I would bring up Andrew
Paul Mooney and somebody else and myself
and I go home
because she paid me she never [__]
said nothing to me but I paid my dues I
was there every [__] week you know
like and that's the grinds and that's
what people have to realize especially
new Comics there is a grind to this
there is a pain in my dues you're not
entitled to anything even now like I
don't maybe I'll never go to a comedy
show but when I get to work with really
big names or great I'm I'm sitting my
ass in the seat if I've opened for them
and watching because that's going to be
part yeah education you're a lifelong
Learner in this I don't think I'm never
ahead of where I'm supposed to be so if
I'm gonna be opening for Joey or opening
for a rich for us or Bobby Kelly I I'm
watching the show after that I've seen
Bobby's new special yeah I just saw it I
was [__] dying to laugh yeah that's a
30-year seasoned [__] oh he's yeah
people don't mention Bobby Kelly how
that dangerous that [__] is I
saw a special that was like half wit
recorded on a phone from Comedy Central
and they did it at this at The Comedy
Cellar but five four years ago in the
whole entire room one night like two in
the morning and a special coming on he
was a lot bigger than he was goofing on
fat people and [__] I was [__]
rolling yeah that's a guy that should be
a lot bigger yeah than what he is I'm
happy not physically just
he just talked about it yeah I just saw
him yelling there's a yeah he's one of
those guys that's been around he'll
[__] murder you I get excited like I
get excited not even for me I get
excited to see what the crowd is gonna
get like because we him and I do a show
called smokes and jokes he's a big cigar
smoker so we've been doing cigar night
comedy shows together and I get so
excited it's one time off because I I
he's gonna do 20 minutes of not Material
he's gonna talk about the ceiling the
lamp make fun of the person in the
audience and it's just it's so like off
the cuff and I get excited to watch the
audience and organic at you I'm excited
and I'm like I'm learning oh look at all
the observations he just made that I
maybe didn't or
it's always great to go see a
a Big Time comic whatever I'll tell you
who my favorite one of my favorite guys
to watch and you guys are gonna [__]
laugh at me
I hate corny [__] but he was so corny he
killed me the guy with the puppets
Jose Jose
the white dude
Jeff Dunham
dangerous [__] instead and I
don't know how many times you know I've
never had a beef with him when I'd see
him he'd give me a hug no matter what
I'd always [__] you know that was
great and he I think he would look at me
and go I don't believe you that you like
my puppet
it's [__] great I mean right there's
some people you know the dude from New
York rest is so that was a puppet act uh
whatever the guy's name was that was
crazy
I used to live down here before he
passed away God Rest his soul the guy
that used to take booking calls or the
phone booth the ventriloquist had a a
big [__] the [__] the dummy had a
baby
the dummy had a [__] and he shaved the
piece off so you could put lines of Coke
in it and snort a line off oh my God how
do I not know come on man this is can we
yeah we need somebody on the computer
come on guy you don't remember this
[__]
Otto and George
[__] George I when I first got the
comedy like no no when I first started
rocking around like maybe 2000 to rock
and roll you know when you're like a
good feature right right well that was a
feature act like in 2007 I saw him for
the first time maybe even before that I
saw him and it was real
he was intense
and he's up there cursing eating [__]
talking about smoking car I mean this
guy was nuts you know word on the street
was that he didn't even have a phone
when you had to book him he gave you a
pay phone and you had to call that pay
phone on a Tuesday behind this house
that's crazy George was the real [__]
deal but anyway not the like Jeff Dunham
I because there was a lot of times I
would do the Late Show behind Jeff Jeff
doesn't do two shows so I go to Irvine
or Brea and it would be just yeah and
the only thing I ever heard negative
about Jeff was I'd get there and the
manager would go listen you know Jeff
loves you but he made us cut your video
is the video that you're coming because
it was always dirty in front of his
audience so he would make them cut that
video you know like when you go to a
comedy show to tell you who's coming up
they always have like a little skip 30
minutes of video like I don't have this
in the movie theater right now I need
this here
dumb [__]
but uh no I liked him a lot and I
learned from him even from a puppet act
I [__] would sit there and look at
their timing timing his timing the
puppet's timing and you're like [__] God
and they gotta be writing behind it
right yeah no he's a real that
[__] was making millions
Duncan was okay with no he only brought
the little hobo out at the end and it
was the creepiest [__] thing in the
world that little guy
I couldn't sleep at the hotel knowing
that he was next door to me with the
puppet
the scariest goddamn thing in the world
but it's so weird how
you have like I can't watch specials
well
I can't watch specials because at the
time how long they are these or well the
time but
it was so surreal for me going down to
the Vinnies one night
and it was the week that uh
Natalie Cuomo was there with Somebody's
Daughter I can't remember Sheba okay
Sheba Sheba has a room in mid yes okay
in the city
no they're not
Amy Schumer they're not Whitney Cummings
but they're getting that they'll be
there someday
them too were the first time I go [__] I
forgot how much I enjoyed watching Life
coming I forgot how much I enjoyed
watching Live Comedy because I had a
whole system that was tremendous
listen I would get stoned as [__] put a
hooded sweatshirt on sunglass you ever
seen my sunglasses huh never you no
never I'd put sunglasses on and I'd walk
in the back of the comedy store and I
just sit there and watch the whole
rotation from nine o'clock up
if a comment got boring I'd walk out but
I'd make sure I was there for the next
one or I'd stay there and watch how he'd
get out of the hole because watching
people get out of a hole always an
education that's another lesson but I
would sit there
I would do that maybe Tuesday nights
Wednesday night when not now when I
first got there so I left in 2007. I
would sit there once a week high and I'd
get pissed when people come and bother
me Joey do you know what to get some
weak the [__] away from me because you
just broke everything you just broke
that like I would put myself in that
corner chair for a [__] reason I
don't want you to say anything to me I'm
just and nobody used to bother you them
for pictures or nothing it was just
sitting there and watching 10 comics in
a row
see how they would rotate because
they're only you know 20 15 minute sets
so I'd watch four or five of them and go
for a walk and come back and then go for
a walk and then come back I loved it I
really enjoyed it when I'm home
I don't get that when I put a special on
I don't get I don't give you Jesus with
the tribe I'm not going to get it as
much as I did I went to see that and I
always knew that this is all the [__]
that's coming back to me because during
the pandemic we forgot a lot about this
[__] but I've always enjoyed just
watching straight up [__] comedy I
don't want to be in a nice place it
could be bricks like give me the
dirtiest clubs in New York those are the
ones I'll probably end up going to I
love dangerfields
and they were like Joey what did you do
we got 21 people I'm like [__] yeah yeah
I love danger I love Dangerfield I did
my first show which has the Dangerfield
comedy event when we did a charity event
there you had the old school like like
how like a mafia restaurant from the 50s
feel still like the lamps were still
like those little lamps were still at
the table everything was red and God
knows they never put the lights on
because you didn't want to know what it
looked like but it had that real like
feel yeah when you watch the specials
that the shout from there and you walk
in there you get it you go wow I could
smell the history in this place I know
when I sat at the bar it was the first
club that it was an honor for me beside
the store to sit at that thing at that
bar
I did it when I was shooting the many
Saints I had never done it before and
when I came back to shoot the money
cents I got a bunch of options where I
could go do spots and none of them
signed this enticing as danger feels and
I would take an Uber up there two three
I would call Linda row she'd get me a
[__] a showcase I would go up there I
would do 20 minutes 15 minutes
eight people yeah but a [__] blast
and that's what I would like to go back
to
I love those kind of rooms where they
don't they don't have enough people for
the chest like there's dirty chairs in
the room and there's 18 people news
can't announce you're going
but boy that's the best workout you'll
ever have because that really gets you
talking it might get you thinking
quickly like this [__] I have at home I
could write three jokes but you know
that one joke the seal them want
together I can't do that now I have to
do that joke on stage that's when that
joke comes completely that last joke to
add to compliment because it's a
complimentation you have to do it on the
stage while I work I just
I don't know those small rooms you have
to talk to people like they always say
that you know you get good in comedy
when you when you just sound like you're
having a conversation but when you write
the jokes you're performing an act when
you have just eight people there you're
not theatrical you're talking to eight
people you gotta learn how to talk to
the people like that's where you learn
your voice and your conversation and
your ad-libbing and your and you know
and you obviously record every set and
it's like nails on a chalkboard so
listen to yourself but that's what you
learn oh oh I hate it in this voice New
York City
and there was I got some good jokes out
of it but I didn't like the whole set
from Saturday night I got I like some
the jokes that I tried I really enjoyed
stuff yeah I really enjoyed that stuff
you played back the whole thing uh I
played back the parts I wanted to hear
the material I'd done I can't listen to
the whole no can't listen I explain
but I I know I still have to do it
doesn't make a difference when you get
to a certain point sometimes I might
just watch it I've been doing a podcast
I don't know how long now
I don't know how many podcasts we've
done and if I've watched five of them
200 episodes of this
you know I don't know how many the
church 100 with Felicia I never really
watched the whole one not because the
podcast wasn't good because I couldn't
stand listen to myself like it's okay
when she's talking but when it goes back
to me that's not what I want to see I
want to see her talking so after a while
I'm like I'm good but isn't that crazy
because you're what everybody wants to
see in here you're you're the draw
you're the draw but yet you yourself
that's it's something there's something
to that
when you think about it
I always thought I was [__] I
thought that was I thought there was a
problem I really thought there was a
problem I could tell you guys things I
did that I'm not proud of that I went to
a a Premiere I would say hello and then
leave
and then try to come back because I
didn't want to watch me
taxi I left
I just went to that Premiere to see
Brady's wife
things at a Premiere you know I went to
see Tom Brady's wife the Brazilian girl
and she's single now
she's single Mackenzie during this
single Jesus Christ yeah Mackenzie
Durham took all the pictures of her
boyfriend off the [__] insta
Instagram people like dog Mackenzie
Durham is single how do we know this
Intel nah that was totally sent me a
message they go Joey this is your chance
yeah Mackenzie is scrapping all her
daddy baby pictures off her Instagram
and I'm like she's single Jesus Christ
but
I thought there was something wrong with
me I never repeated it because I've
heard of people we have a mutual friend
not a friend I heard this [__]
went to a Super Bowl
I know for a fact he went to a Super
Bowl one day there were 50 people at the
[__] thing and during the Super Bowl
Halftime he goes enough with this let's
put a tape up in my stand up
at his house or something can you
imagine me going to your [__] house
with your parents and everybody
and this was the guy wasn't even famous
not he's never been famous but God was
never nobody knew who he was he went to
a party for the Super Bowl the year I
got to California somebody told me like
two weeks later I could stay away from
this [__]
people were in the room the guy who
invited was real he went over there I
know who he's saying and he found that
[__] tape and during the [__]
Super Bowl and somebody yelled take it
off I mean it's not good no I don't even
I don't know the story specifically and
once we're off camera I'm gonna okay
if I guess you're right but I hate that
story that story you can see how that
story stayed with me because I always
thought about what would possess
a comic to go to a super party and throw
his VHS tape in at halftime
and force people to watch it
if I had the best out of my life I still
couldn't take that tape and make you put
on
at the Super Bowl you wouldn't even put
it on YouTube no no I wouldn't put it
anywhere
but that's a that's a character trait
and we see them in this industry right
that that's that's not just that that's
somebody that openly asks for things
that they're not entitled to that's like
there's a whole element here like even
me wanting to do this podcast I didn't
ask directly you know maybe somebody
said something to Joey or it
I have always like I wouldn't have the
balls like I I couldn't do that I don't
know if it's like the way we are like
that New York I think he's an Italian
but he's not that New York New Jersey
Italian like no you don't like you do
you do you do hard work you you know you
do good and then things come to you like
that's a different level of ego that's
entitlements that's and that we see it
we see it with Comics or people who want
to be Comics or but like there's a I've
never I've asked one person for help
the whole time like and it was like
pandemic and I just was in like a rut
and it was rituals
he's the only person I ever reached out
to and said I and and I I worded it in a
way that was like almost like I wasn't
worthy of the uh and he's like what are
you talking about of course that you're
gonna deliver I'm gonna recommend you
somewhere and they're gonna do you're
gonna do good you're gonna do great and
then but I was like I've never asked
before
and so when I hear these things or these
people asking for these opportunities
you go I'm never gonna make it in this
industry because I'm never I'm never
gonna have that I'm gonna take the
longest road possible to get there
because I'm never gonna come from that
you don't come from that no but there's
two sides to that and I gotta be honest
with you
number one something they told you an
Italian house and a Cuban house and they
told you you're in church on every
Sunday when you went with your family is
if you asked you will receive yes so
let's let's let's I understand where
you're coming from because I got the
same problem I could never just ask
somebody I feel a lot better if they
contact me then they'll you know a
conversation will come up like somebody
asked me if I ever did two years ago if
I did that thing that they were doing
that summer and I go no I never did it I
wanted to and somebody called an ass but
we never really put it together you know
listen you're right I had a problem my
first 10 years economy maybe 15 years of
Comedy
nobody knew I did comedy
because it was introduced to me like
when I started going on the road I swear
to God I remember going on the road as a
MC and the club owner going Saturday and
Friday you have to go to the mall and
give away tickets
and I like I quit I'm not going and guys
you know I'm outspoken you know I like
having a good time you I can go up to a
woman and go listen I got an eight ball
of coke when we go back to your house
and suck your [__] like I'm one of
those creepy [__] but not do
you want to come to a comedy show I
cannot I know I couldn't bark either go
hi hi what are you ladies doing tonight
don't you want to come to a badass
comedy show and they're like I don't
know that's that I know I know so
because of that I suffered my career
your career suffers if you're not that
type of person
but then something came that took the
place of me my boss social media right
so now those are my balls now those are
where I got my balls from you know it's
weird that and I I'm an ashamed to say
this
you know I I didn't want to quit cocaine
because I thought it would take away
from my comedy that's such a common it's
like people say I didn't want to lose
weight because then I wouldn't get hired
for rolls this is all a stupid thing
that you have in your mind
when I got off cocaine my sex life went
down the tooth
in more ways than one because that was
my courage
even with my wife
that was my courage that's how I went
out at night I'll ask that chick if she
wants to suck dick you know what I'm
saying or whatever I could ask anybody
anything when I had a couple lines in me
or a cocktail you know what are you
gonna put me on that stage soon after
Danny Merwin time at the Tempe Improv we
had just done a line of coke I'd snorted
coke and daddy walked in the room I
didn't snort coke with him and I
remember we were talking like what I
have to do to go in your room the
funniest feature up here and he's like
I'll contact you obviously I still
remember that story because it irked me
for the rest of my life because that's
the [__] I could do when I was coked up
right but I couldn't do it when I was
sober
but then I realized once social media
came that you have to let people know
so I did it through social media don't
be like I was never gonna go out and
hang on a fly right now I know I can't
pass out a fly come to the shop I'm not
going to pass flies out in the cars you
know I'm not going to do those things
you retweet my things that's like
passing out flyers so it's
it's that helped me yeah I even look at
it I didn't even make that comparison as
to what that is it's false
but and and to your point and and not
against what I said but our mutual
friend Kathy when I was telling her like
when I was in Iran she's like well ask
them I'll ask this person if you're like
no no don't ask anybody anything and
she's like she goes I don't want to
she's very blunt she's like I'm gonna
say this to insult you but you're having
a very ignorant neighborhood mentality
right now
and I was like
um what what do you mean and she was
like that get out of that like in this
industry people ask for things like you
gotta ask speak up you know you know and
the same with you like ask you gotta get
fed right and I'm like when she said it
I was like you know because I think I'm
not that right I'm not this ignorant
neighborhood girl but that was the
mentality that she was kind of saying
that I had
you have to promote yourself and
some people it comes to very easily you
know Dane Cook was very good at it on
Facebook on MySpace he was very good at
it and
but all those things I can never do so I
could never put a tape in a [__]
Super Bowl but
I thought I was in bad shape and then
one night I got home early from the
store and Johnny Depp
was on Letterman this has to be
maybe 2010 I mean 2009 around there
because I felt better after
and they were talking about the Pirates
of the Caribbean and you know so when
you did the Pirates how the Daly's
looking and he goes I don't know
and he goes what do you mean you're the
star of the show and you don't know what
the dailies look like
and John debka Johnny Depp goes I don't
look at those I don't like looking at
myself on video and he goes you're the
one of the most handsome man in the
world Johnny Johnny Depp went into the
same Spiel that I tell people I mean he
just went into it I do not watch myself
I can't listen to myself if I'm walking
in a room and I hear my voice I [__]
cringe he was just telling my story and
I'm like oh my God okay I'm not [__]
I'm not there's not something you know
mentally off of me this is Johnny Depp
he looks like that
he looks like that okay I look like this
but he looks like that and he don't want
to be seen or he don't want to see
himself so it all came full circle I
understood it so you have to work with
it I knew it was it just wasn't me you
know me I could The Longest Yard the
crew screening I stayed at
the premiere I did not stay at
when I went to grudge match with my
buddies I got up and left
I got up and went outside they stayed
and watched Grudge Match I'll do it a
couple minutes but once I start popping
up in the screen
I gotta get out of there that's
uncomfortable for a guy like me
yes it makes me feel I don't want to be
that guy I'm up next
you want me to tell what it feels like
it feels like they made a movie and put
my [__] image in there because I'm
looking at it going what am I doing in
that [__] movie that's like imposter
syndrome like yeah it's like what am I
doing that [__] thing I'm a [__]
felon I grew up in Jersey we don't make
movies
you do but you do I do right but in my
mind
let me stand upsets come on
it's hard because the only way to really
learn what you're doing and what is to
listen and to watch but in the same part
I'm like I don't want to see because I
don't want to overthink it the next time
I get on stage not to do this or not to
do that but it's like I will tell you
what 22. I will tell you what I will do
I will take a short set of mine like a
YouTube set of mine and watch it and
keep it very low
and I know what I'm saying but I want to
watch my body movements
because I know if I had a body movement
for this joke they'll push the joke
through you know that I'll do but again
did you hear what I said sure hello set
six
seven minutes ten minutes
I could tolerate that if one of my girls
come downstairs that thing gets taken
off the computer faster than anything
the only thing I will watch to learn
from
because I think it's the only really
spectacular job I've ever done is Ari
shafriya's storytelling show the sister
Hyacinth I really like that one that was
something that I sat there with a pen
from the end to the beginning and worked
on very hard and that's why it came out
that good I never worked that hard on my
stand-up
but I enjoyed the story concept of doing
it because I just like it it's a
but that's the only time I can watch
myself wow
that [__] is shooting the special and
coming home every night and listening to
your sets from the flappers and haha
that [__] almost killed me
so by the time I got to the special I
was so beat up from the shitty material
I didn't know where I was coming from
that's why I'm not a special comic right
I don't like shooting specials it
doesn't work everybody has a different
knock my knock is I don't do a good
special and I know we're going in I
don't ever want to do it again I like
going up there and just killing with no
but I like there and I won't mention
them but there are Comics I love that I
think are great that I watch the special
I'm like oh they should just people
should just see them live
that's why I want to record him when
he's not aware of it that's a great idea
I mean obviously just for him no I know
because that's the other thing like I
know there's gonna be a camera on me
Saturday but yeah right
but it's it's a different it's a
different level I haven't even known
comedy for now uh full-time like 10
years and then before that I don't count
those three of you know those three or
four years of getting up and working
right in my first few bits from the time
you got a dollar okay that seems fair
so you're ready
10 years you're a veteran you know 10
years of Comedy you already know what's
going on you know you really know what's
going on I feel like I'm fine I really
found my voice you know what's going on
you get yourself out of this situation
it's just finding more material and now
you're on the upswing of building a
following momentum getting a movie or a
TV show to complement the credits it's
such a [__] and again even like young
Comics I couldn't wait to get a credit
when you bring me up when people bring
me up and they come to me they go what
do you want me to Sago nothing
you worked so hard for those credits for
anybody who knows you can't wait to have
a credit I can't wait I got to use this
as a credit yeah oh [__] oh [__] and
then you have like three of them and
you're like oh [__] oh [__] and then
when they like don't say nothing I just
wanna
cry yeah I'm using Uncle I was just
appeared on Uncle Joey's joints like the
next year no no no no no you're right it
is you
there's so many comedy is such a great
journey for people and the journey
starts
it really starts at the 10-year Mark but
guess what it gets better at the 20 and
more
and people see that and it's like you
telling me if I join the Army I have to
stay till for 20 years when you're 18
that seems like a [__] eternity but
it's really not guys if you're at home
right now listening to this it's not we
we look at time like I still remember I
blew I almost blew my life
because I would my friends could get me
union jobs whether it was longshoreman
jobs brick Mason's job but when they
tell me it was a four-year
apprenticeship I'm like
I'm not doing that I do a four-week
apprenticeship man I want to get paid
like well these [__] aren't
here because you don't see that kind of
time in your life
but once you're there and you're like
I've been doing this [__] for 10 years
10 years is The Sweet Spot in comedy
and that's like when I was watching the
show and I was getting upset watching
Last Comic Standing I go well I should
have started I started the I should have
done it then and I should have done it
now and then I'm like you know what
Sarah 10 years from now you're gonna say
I wish I started then
and I'm gonna go oh my God why didn't
you know I said so just start it's it's
you just have to start it sounds so
cliche and corny but it's like you just
have to start
that's why when people come to me and
they go hey man I'm just listen there's
two things everybody hates to hear
are you gonna join Jiu Jitsu no I'm
gonna let me get in shape to come in
there you're never going to change the
shape you know it's like people it's
like people trying to tell me I'm not
going to join the gym till I get in
shape
you know and would stand up when people
call them if you paid me 500 and said
Joe I want you to give me an hour
tutoring I go how about I give you 475
back and give me I'll take 25 for the
best advice I could give you don't even
worry about your material the first two
or three times on stage don't even worry
about go up then tell me a story but you
can I'd rather you do that than be up
there clunky I just want you to get over
the mechanics of it I focused a lot on
my words and it almost cost me my career
because I kept saying I'm not going to
go off until I write well you're not
going to [__] write you've never
written before what makes you think
you're going to become [__] Lenny
Bruce now
get up there I tell people just get just
go up there you're gonna 80 chances are
you're gonna bump
and it's not gonna really matter
nobody's ever going to remember it I
don't care if you go up on an open mic
at a bar whatever is easier for you
karaoke they all count
get up there the only way to get good is
to be bad yeah I learned if I had a
great night and killed I learned more
from a night when I did it I never say I
killed so let me at 10 years I still
don't say I ever killed but if I had a
great night if I had a bad night I you
know of course the next morning I'm like
I'm quitting I'm quitting this isn't for
me you never you know you don't quit but
you I learned so much more from those
nights
I would never quit I would just tell
myself
that was a piece of [__] that what made
me think
I could ever do this and then you go
okay I'll give this another month and if
you don't [__] make it work I'm done
with you comedy and then
something good happens that's what
happened I would get into a place where
I'd be like how am I doing this with my
life I'm giving everything up for this
to pursue this dream and then you have a
bad night you'd be like this is I'm not
a comic this isn't for me and then boom
you get something or you get it and
you're like it's like it takes one good
night to erase dirty bad
and then you're right back you're right
back into the like oh I can do this now
think about it people are at home right
now watching this that conversation you
just said you think you're crazy
if you said that to me 30 years ago I'm
like you're [__] crazy I gotta have
30 Bad nights
did I have one good night you're [__]
crazy
but explain to them how good that night
is that one good one night it's like I'm
I found who I am like I'm I know what
I'm meant to do and it's like an
actualization like it's you can't really
explain it it's just like this is who I
am like and you if you find yourself in
that night and you go this is it I'm
gonna do whatever I gotta do to feel
this again and then of course it's a
different level of Chase when you get to
a certain level you know when you you
know one great night great but I should
have been you know I should have you
start going oh where you want to be like
where I wanted to be 10 years ago now
I'm not as grateful as maybe I should be
right because now I'm looking at the
next 10 years so you kind of really
humble yourself and in these times and I
gotta say this is where I wanted to be
this is exactly what I wanted to do be
happy with where you are now but it's
hard when you get into this but that one
those good nights man it's
it's the best feeling in the world why
that's why I'm here you know I want to
write another book about like
that experience like I didn't really
dive into it in my book like that
experience
from 1991 to
2 000.
if I look at my life those were the best
nine years of my life and I slept in
cars I had to borrow money to do
showcases
the one Club gave me six weeks of work
and then a month later they shot all the
clubs down after I drove 14 hours each
way you know you don't want to tell this
to people because but it's all part of
this [__] thing that's so close to
your heart when you really really look
at it like go like you know traveling
the states and meeting different people
like being stuck in a town and somebody
helps you and you're like
the world is a [__] vampire you know
what I'm saying like the world is a
great place that people will come to
your help even when and talk nobody knew
who I was
when I was getting 50 000 the triple
runs a show no you know nobody even
acknowledges yet okay you're the guy
under the headliner and I still wouldn't
trade in for anything else I still
remember sleeping in hotels where it was
owned by Hindu people and you could
smell the curry coming into the events
all night and [__] like that and the
whole hotel smell you know I can't but
it's all part of the [__] The
Experience like when you look at getting
to Rock Springs Wyoming and the hotel
saying we only got one room you got to
spend the night with the headliner in
the same room and he's snoring and he
hates La you know and he's one of those
[__] negative Headliners these are
all educate that's all part of who you
are like this is what's on my sleeve now
and you need that thick skin in this
industry and that makes you stronger
that makes you tougher like you
and that thick skin is going to go with
you forever you need to rip your this
the scab off your soul and build it back
because it's going to come in handy
in 15 years it's going to come in handy
in 20 years and that's a lot of people
everybody's in such a rush they miss
those early steps and then you're gonna
have to go back so do them now that's
why my model has always been you could
pay me now
or you could pay me later I didn't
invent the pencil did in the [__] 80s
if you don't change your oil in your car
and this is a word from our sponsor
but it's the truth and I know for a fact
it goes with comedy because let me tell
you what's happening with comedy today
that's what she's gonna say [__] and
you know this what's happening with
Conley today and I have nothing against
these people
is that a guy makes a video on YouTube
social media then he makes another video
on YouTube then he makes another video
on YouTube he gets like 10 million
downloads now somebody just says to him
you should just do stand up
well I don't know how it happened you
know it could happen that way or they
are doing stand up online cracking
little jokes and then they start going
into clubs and they go into clubs with a
following
yeah which I didn't have a following I
never forget David tell came up to me in
Miami one night he goes dog I like what
you're doing as a feature act because
you are building a following because
when you do hit later on these people
are going to feel responsible they saw
you and they're going to come out and
see you even more and it's the truth
whenever I go to Miami let's play
Houston people come up to me and go I
remember seeing you open for rogue in 98
when you took your dick out and you
chase the [__] penguin across the you
know how could they forget how can they
forget no but it's true all that builds
and people don't know that so this
YouTube sensation that you got he's got
30 million he sells out the Improv yeah
and this is all great but he's
performing in front of this crowd
he's performing in front of his own
people he never won one over right this
is what's happened with you two you
never want to crowd over they come in to
see you and you attack now one day Bob
Kelly is gonna come up to you and go hey
why don't we go do a set of Gotham why
don't we set up The Comedy seller and
you're going to go up in front of the
audience that isn't you
and it's gonna shock you to no [__]
you could not say it you could have not
made a better comparison to what that is
I know not good
I see it now when like uh you know and
let's not be a feature act if it's a big
enough name of somebody selling out you
know say oh this this you know this kid
sold out you know the club or whatever
and I gotta do 35 or 40 minutes as an
opener you don't got an act
you just filled seats
and it's crazy when you see that and
then they go oh you know you were great
I couldn't follow or yeah well you have
to do you know before you put your name
because you want people to come back to
see you and and it's an easy mistake
listen you get popularity like that you
think like anything else oh I can do it
we have to be respected in it either no
you're not gonna get respected because
you deserve no respect right but then
you go up in front of your audience
these audiences and they're blowing
smoke up your ass and that's not that's
unhealthy I know it's not healthy not to
mention you over skipped the MC the
process of EMC and you over skip the
process where you grow the most yeah
they're there for a reason those two
positions are there for a reason don't
you have to go to the ranks for a reason
okay you went through the Army you went
to college you got your officer now
you're coming as an officer so that
means you're coming as a [__] MC
that's what that means you don't come in
as a [__] you know somebody else
you're coming as a
and watch this and listen we [__] uh
a guy who like I took a comedy class it
was a three-week class and what didn't
really cover right he told me to get
Judy Carter's book and then Judy Carter
took it from there yes whatever
so
but I did those ranks
I bombed I still remember
going to a room that started at 11. and
the guy coming up to me 15 minutes going
15 more minutes 15 more minutes and it's
1 15. and there's eight people left and
you invited six of your friends to come
see you when they drove you and they
took you to dinner you know these these
things you know I'm gonna forget doing
the Latin Comedy Festival for the Toyota
Comedy Festival the Latin thing at
Caroline's and that comic threw me to
the Wolves he [__] made me follow a
salsa band because he didn't like me at
the end he put the salsa band up right
now everybody's dancing they're moving
the show is done
and that stays with you for a long time
you're like how could I like when I got
off the stage that night how could I
have handled that better and I went home
and took my notebook in the middle while
I go no you can't handle that that's
that's not what has to happen you go up
before the [__] band they did like
three songs of Caroline I know that's
yeah the guy kept saying to me but
you're really you're really strong go up
after them and I'm like I'm not [__]
strong what the [__] are you talking
about it doesn't make a difference how
strong you are you've just changed the
whole Vibe of the room the whole energy
are you excited for Saturday night I am
excited for Saturday I am how long have
you been working this material for
I put some new stuff in there which
almost you would never do but if I don't
like it take it out yeah so it's some of
my I even took some of my first jokes
that I don't even do anymore because I
want to have everything out there and
then see what is I really want like what
I want on this album because this is my
first real intro and then uh
you do know that your life is going to
be held next Monday
once you're out of material oh oh I know
oh it's it's like a double-edged wood
like um part of me is like oh my God
that's it now like now you have to start
back to the drawing board but there's
also a part of me that's like I don't
want to do those jokes anymore
so it's like
it's I I you know I feel it like
I'm really proud of you that you're
doing this and it's so crazy to say that
again another thing that's crazy
you can't wait to put together your
jokes and you can't wait to go tell them
and what a great feeling it is to
[__] write a new act and you're
enjoying it and jokes are flying out
here
but then all of a sudden you shoot this
[__] special and now what and now
you're out of jokes what's that gonna be
like tell me okay so now you're gonna
what we discussed you're gonna have your
leftover jokes that you didn't that they
didn't take in the special and you have
that left over so you can take it what
you have and take that material from a
different direction
I would just start from scratch and it's
brutal
it's brutal
it's what I was going through the last
six months here trying to do material
and you know not uh
not being able to grow with it you know
like the last six months I've had a hard
time [__] writing in
so
now I'm okay I wrote some great stuff
for this week but when you shoot a
special you have to go up there for like
two weeks and find the hook then once
you find the hook you're like thank God
I got three minutes then you have seven
minutes and then you go oh [__] I wrote
a joke close to this a year ago let me
go back in that notebook and get that
joke out that I I couldn't fix it with
anything else and that's how you start
putting things together and then you're
up to 20 minutes and you're fine because
now at least you could do sets right you
got 20 minutes yeah it's to when you
don't have any material I know and you
got to go up there and start from
scratch and that's that's why in fact
I'm telling you that's what I had to do
and since I was out of the comedy
listen when you do comedy every night 10
years 15 years and I've said it on here
before you become your mind is sharp
like if you see something you process it
right away it's very funny
the pandemic and what I was going
through took me away from that state of
mind
we weren't really seeing any right which
the state of mind is which when we're
driving and I can just come up with a
joke when I see somebody right now I'm
starting to get it back I still have the
ability I have at the last week's show I
could tell the joke writing is starting
to come back it's taking a lot longer
than I wanted to
but we weren't living during the
pandemic I feel like in order and I I I
realized this now and I don't want to
take a break or I feel like I gotta get
up every night I'm like I gotta live
life in order to joke about it
and I feel like
we're kind of getting back to our groove
and that's why it's coming back now and
that's why yeah but there were some
people who went right back on the horse
like I thought comedy clubs are going to
be packed all these Comics are going to
go back and do their regime and go back
to a club start the scratch pack of
material and get to theaters and stuff
no it was a weak land and most Comics
went right back to where they were right
back to a theater you know for me I I
but I look at things a lot differently I
don't like going up there
just to crack jokes I want them to get
something I want them to get an hour
from me and that's not always possible
you know I'm not going to have that
ability at all times because like even
now I feel like I'm doing okay but I'm
not I'm not joking I just saw you and
you I just saw you perform well by Uncle
Vinnies two weeks ago
I feel comfortable now but I'm not where
I was before the pandemic
it's taking a long time and correct I
haven't been working out like I would in
L.A like I knew different rooms
everything was a lot closer to me
but I'm I'm feeling it again and it's
been [__] fun you know it's good to
hear you say that I think you scared
some people when you were like yeah I'm
not gonna do it anymore everybody was
like I don't I don't want to do to the
extent I was doing it
but I don't want to do like somebody
offered me a tour next year
and I thought about it I didn't say no
yet I haven't said anything
I just was like
I don't know because because why though
because it's taxing when you think about
it like or because is it you're at a
point now where you can allow balance in
your life like I feel like when you
first start you're not gonna get there's
no balance there's like a Funnel Vision
there's no such thing as balance there's
no balance at all but nothing but now
you've got a beautiful home you're
giving your daughter a completely
different childhood than she would have
had back in La you have different
friends there are different things
you're interested you're going out to
dinner tonight with friends instead of
going to a club or do you think that's
why because you're trying to find that
happy meeting like why would you say no
to a tour
not that you have said no [__]
weekends man that's my [__] weekend
giving up my weekends for 30 years yeah
okay so now I have something to do on
the weekends but you don't even have to
perform on a weekend no no I could still
perform on Thursdays and Wednesdays or
Thursdays but the whole thing seems
taxing to me I'm at a point right now in
my life where I want to be home a little
more the world's not the [__] great
place right now I enjoy doing my shows
in the city when I go to the city with
you that's a good time and that's what I
can handle right now
what's going to happen next July next
August I don't know but for right now
I'm just getting my bearings back I
don't I didn't want to get into this
from day one I didn't want to go know
where I was before with the podcast or
with the stand-up career I wanted to cut
it down a little bit I didn't want it to
be 20 hours a day this was 20 hours a
day in my life for the last 30 [__]
years not for the last 12 years it's
been 20 hours a [__] day and it's not
performing or Doing Things instrumental
it's the thinking and the jokes and the
you know you're not a a feature anymore
people are actually paying forty dollars
to come see you a babysitter or dinner
you can't go up there like just treat
them like that so
and that's why you're so good because
you're not thinking of you when you're
on that stage the best Comics are
thinking about the audience I'm thinking
about the audience man I don't I under I
don't like what's going on today I don't
like that audiences are paying too
enough to see a comic or 299. that's
absurd these Comics could make a living
on 30 tickets just like I [__] did
for years
so I always think about the audience I
want them Jesus Christ when the comic
tells me that I haven't written a joke
in a year I'm done with you I'm done
with you
I'm done with you I told my wife how can
nothing happen in a year man nothing
that's what you're telling me that
nothing happened in your life in a
[__] Year tell me about the car that
spent by your house and almost hit your
[__] kid
you know tell me something something has
had to happen so when you think like
that you always got to be uh on top of
it when you're writing and stuff I don't
want that no more I have a child now
I have a wife now I could be writing in
my child to come up to me go dead you
want to go play basketball I can't just
go no no no I'm writing a joke I can't
do that no more can't do that no more so
I'm like I said I'm doing the best and
the most that I can do right now and
that's it and that's it do I think about
getting on a plane on a Friday night on
a Thursday
and doing that second show yeah that
should be sailed no uh I considered even
doing a Friday night tour a Saturday
night tour
like just Saturday nights
how I want to do it is not how most
people want to do it it would cost a lot
more because I'm not doing [__]
commercial flights anymore oh I'm not
doing anything I'm not doing them so if
somebody wants to do a tour I'll even
take less money
and figure out a way just to [__] get
out of there after my show get off stage
at 11 you're on a plane at [__] 11
15. like Rogan's in Atlantic City which
the girl does every night they get out
of that town they get to the next town
the next day that's what I would like to
do but
I I first of all I never liked doing
Tuesday through Saturday
this whole last run I did was never it
was always Thursday Friday Saturday
that's it no Sundays Wednesday I don't
have time for you you know I don't mind
doing the city on a Wednesday right I go
to the stand tonight with you yeah
danger feels but that's where I am right
now that's where I am I still love
comedy like I did when I first got on
that stage I still love it it's just I
had to love it in a different way now I
have more people to love when I got into
and I noticed in La I don't know how
many nights I would be at dinner and she
just said prayers
and I gotta get dressed go to the store
and talk about eating ass and shooting
somebody and you know it's like and then
you start thinking about the mafia
oh you joined the Mafia When You're 18.
or 23 or 24 because you're shooting
people you don't give a [__] about
shooting people but then you bump into a
beautiful girl at the deli and you have
beautiful children with her and now I
gotta go shoot somebody and go take my
daughter to church tomorrow take it to
the daddy daughter dance like it was
surreal to me that's what I would feel
like I'd be there watching the same
press and with the same in my mind I'm
like oh I'm gonna go down to The Comedy
Store I'm gonna smoke some dope I can't
do this no more it just wasn't working
so I have a lot more people that need my
attention now
I'm not the you know guys I comedy is
Never Growing Up
stand up gives you the permission to
Never Grow Up and I love that about
Santa because I never wanted to grow up
if you become a comedian it's because
you don't want to grow up I became a
comedian because I liked it like you
liked watching it but when I read Lenny
Bruce's book I like the fact that when I
read that book I was lost I was a
criminal I was a drug addict
he hung out of the strip club and he
went to the Chelsea Hotel and he went to
sleep and he shot heroin with jazz
musicians
that's what I wanted I didn't want to
shoot heroin right but I wanted to smoke
drink all night and especially in New
York what a dream it would be to leave
your house like if I was a comic that
slept all day oh all right get up at
seven eat some Chinese food smoke some
pot make some calls and then leave at 10
o'clock at night and just attack New
York come on dog that's a dream come
true stop at two go get a slice of pizza
go with Target a late steak somewhere in
the village and then you go home at five
in the morning and there's another party
going on at the Chelsea Hotel cope
[__] strippers who wouldn't dream of
that that's a [__] Paradise that's a
that's why I got into company because it
gave me permission to be yourself not to
grow up when you get into comedy how
many bills you got yeah no I know like I
told Lisa you ever see somebody come up
in an open mic with a Lamborghini nobody
ever pulls up a Lamborghini an open mic
right everywhere else you could be at a
coffee shop beep beep nobody ever pulls
up in a Lamborghini so
I I didn't have anything when I got into
comedy and now I have people like I
never thought I always thought I was
going to die like Charles Bronson like
alone in my house you know in a basement
apartment with a cat drinking from a
bowl like in in heart but that's it
that's the only but then all these
things came that take your time your
health you know when you're a comic you
don't really think about health that's
how I met Joe Rogan you're on the road I
remember the first time run goes you
want to work out I'm on the road [__]
what workout your body your health all
these things come in
and no that's the god truth
I don't want to go out like Bob Saget no
I don't want to die in a hotel room yeah
not now 20 years ago I want to die in a
hotel room with a naked woman sitting on
my face but now
I want to die right here and you found
your balance and and this is and this is
this is the gift and I still love the 30
years right yeah I still love stand up I
have to find a different way to do it
and if it means going to Uncle Vinnie's
on Thursdays for a year and doing the
New York uh the Sony theater Sony Hall
once a month so be it
once I get more room listen Chappelle
took off eight years
oh yeah and he waited to his kids in two
years my daughter's not going to want to
do nothing with me already I told him I
have to go to Cincinnati for this movie
and she's like that's okay Dad I just
come and visit you that was not her
stance that was not the response he
wanted either yeah that was not her
stance two months ago right so I know in
two years you should go Dad you can do
whatever you want and I'll take more
advantage of that you know who knows
what the future brings but today is the
best I could do because you you found
how to be in the present and that's not
that's something we you get you as a new
comic you're never gonna get that oh
and as a 32 year old loser I was never
going to get that as a 44 year old Louis
I was going to get that I needed
somebody something to happen to make me
overhaul everything and it was that
little girl I mean I love being here I
love the softball game last night was
the only dad at softball practice I sat
by myself the moms reacting you know
that's what moms do
I sat by myself I love all this you had
a beautiful place to be when you could
be calm like that did you ever think
years ago you could just be sitting at a
soft belt like even now like I drive by
one my husband will be like you're ready
for that you want kids you ready and I'd
be like you and your mother better be
ready because I ain't doing that I'm
gonna be in comedy clubs every night I'm
not doing that so I'm not ready for that
at my age I I love for what you're
saying believe it or not I long for that
level even if it's not with a kid with a
level of peace
that I don't think I have yet because
I'm still
climbing and I'm still digging and
finding my you don't want peace I don't
think I was looking for peace when I was
45 but there is a part of me that says
like I'm listening to say that I'm like
that's gotta be so peaceful
I don't have that level of Peace I've I
have to take things to have that level
of Peace listen man I had but I also had
to make sacrifices right like it was
very rough to lose the comedy salary oh
it was very rough but I looked at my
wife and I go we'll make it work
I put more albums I'm serious you know
there's always [__] you could do you
know
but you have to close one door
before another one opens and people
don't understand that when they like
they want their life to change your
life's not going to change no matter how
much you want it
you have to make sacrifices and then
life will make sense the universe will
make sacrifices and you'll meet in the
middle
for me to attain this peace and to be
able to go to sleep at 11 again I look
at my whoop watch and I sleep till
[__] eight and I'm getting REM sleep
again you know yeah I know for me to
attain that I couldn't attain it by
going on the road every night so I had
to give something up and I gave up the
thing that most people can't give up is
money I stepped away from the money if
the money's in the universe they'll come
to you whether you do this I might hit
the lotto tomorrow you don't know I
might hit 60 million I told you I had
money coming to me
so we always have money coming to us
when you're a good person and you do
good things the universal smile down on
you but I had to cut away a lot of stuff
that made me joy I I narrowed down my
standard to what was going on let's be
honest since we're being honest today
and I won't want you young Comics to
learn something
I wasn't addicted to Comedy anymore
there was nothing about comedy I liked
towards the end there was nothing about
comedy that made me want I didn't want
to go oh I can't wait to try that new
joke in front of Tara she's gonna love
it can't wait to try that new joke in
front of Mike I would get on a plane
with the sole exceptions can't wait for
Saturday night but I put that check in
my hand for the theaters
I got addicted to the check and and I
became a different person when the check
was put in my hand
once the check was put in my hand
the weekend ended don't I won't take no
more pictures I don't want to talk about
comedy no more I mean I was dead serious
about it people never understood that
because that's not who I it just wasn't
working I was doing everything off that
check
the only thing I did that was pure was
go do my fifteen dollar set at The
Comedy Store
that's what kept me pure but everything
else was too out there for me I wanted
to get that love back and until I get
that desire back like I told you that at
seven o'clock I'm telling my wife where
the [__] is dinner I gotta get the [__]
out of here to go to the stress Factory
got them when that happens I'll call you
and let you know but that's not what the
case has been I miss doing comedy
I miss it I Miss The Comedy Store I
Missed The Comedy Store
but I have to just see where I'm at and
I'll come back to it or you move from
here I really proved my point
I proved my point I didn't to me I
couldn't keep going back on the road I I
was starting to see that already with my
friends I just learned that from Ralphie
how many times you're gonna live in
Columbus Ohio
how many times you're gonna go to
Houston Texas and we try to hide it with
different venues or this one time we'll
do the Improv and it'll be different
yeah different experience and then we'll
they get you another feed and then they
get you a bigger bigger theater then
they get you a bigger bigger Theater now
you're in a [__] Arena which is not
good I don't want to do comedy in a
[__] Arena it's more personalized for
me so I didn't want to even to get that
way like when I was seeing these guys
going into Arena I go that would be nice
that's a paid day but at the same time
you sacrifice you fact you sacrifice the
real art of time people are watching on
a [__] screen and you're missing so
much and you're missing so much so I
don't want people to miss that the same
way I enjoy life the live experience I
want to give people that live experience
it's intimate yeah the intimate you know
500 seats
probably put it on anybody knows I could
probably sell another thousand tickets
every night yeah I don't
in fact I wish Sony Hall was 350.
I wish it was 250 sometimes but because
I would have more control I could start
from there again I don't want to go up
in front of a 2000 seat Arena I don't
know I started Uncle Dino's for a reason
Uncle Vinnies I'm dealing with 140
people
and if it's a bad night we'll have 80.
we've never had a bad night so we can
work with that so that's where I'm at
and listen that's where I'm at
comfortable sacrifices then you have to
your life is not going to change you
have to make the initial things
and yeah after
I said no I ate dick for three or four
months you know like money wasn't coming
in but at the same time then movies
started coming in and other things
started coming in why because you got to
close one door before another one opens
and now when I'm ready I'll go back to
stand up when I'm ready to go and I
could be the most effective thing in the
world but right now I can't I don't have
it but you have it to do other things
the rewards around this in other ways
whether it's the softball game for you
or or doing an audition or getting a new
part there's other app you know it's
it's
from one thing came another let me tell
you something I've had more auditions in
the last six weeks than I've had the
last 10 years for years do you see I'm
saying so in the years like when I was
in LA I would get three or four
auditions in a year or some of you make
an offer here at least I'm getting set
like in the last six six weeks I've
probably gotten seven auditions because
the agency realized they're not going to
get blood out of a tournament
see there's a value old man they got to
get that value from me but if I shoot
them down with the road that's why else
I did this right to pick their [__]
up I'm not going on your road so you can
take that week and shut up your ass get
me some auditions and that's what they
did I forced their hand
so there's always a method to the
madness it's like the great Niche he
said it didn't need she say this a man
without a plan is not a man
I like it I'm really proud of you for
what you're doing thank you Joey for
having me both shows start at 9 30. one
Friday's nine on Saturdays nine both of
them are nine nine okay so Uncle
Vinnie's
[__] uh Friday and Saturday I wish
you all luck in the world you're [__]
the sweet lady thank you you're funny as
[__] thank you I see you taking over
this [__] [__] do it
keep on doing what you're doing thank
you I love you [__] don't
forget Tara where can they find you Tara
jokes everywhere because nobody can say
my last name
is my website Tara jokes Instagram Tick
Tock Twitter I love you [__]
stay black have a great week and we'll
see you next Monday tip top Magoo
all right you bad [__] I want
to thank you guys for uh
listen to the show today I want to
apologize for coming up the stairs I had
a a [__] podcast on Tuesday uh
audition on Tuesday I didn't even tell
you about today we'll talk about that
next week and that's it but listen the
joint is brought to you by DraftKings
tonight there's a great game Chicago
Washington DraftKings is going to be
there the official sports betting part
of the NFL tonight you put five dollars
in the NFL team to win and if it comes
in you get 200 and free bets and you
build up your bankroll everyone can
boost their winnings with DraftKings
stepped up same game parlays this
tonight I like Chicago what the [__]
Washington's been struggling now to make
things sweetie tonight you can go for a
total and a [__] sign with a stepped
up same game parlay and you can play
them once a day all season long download
the DraftKings Sportsbook app now use
promo code Joey to get 200 in free bets
if your team wins when you place a five
dollar bet any football team that's
coach Joey only at DraftKings Sportsbook
the official sports betting part of the
NFL minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details now go win some money download
the DraftKings Sportsbook app or the
fantasy app and go knock them out of the
park the joint is also brought to you by
bluetooth listen one of the scariest
things for a young man is not being able
to perform
he'll destroy your [__] confidence
but don't worry about nothing Uncle Joey
got you with Bluetooth
is an online service that delivers the
same active ingredient as Viagra and
Cialis but in chewable tablets all had a
fraction of a cost you could take them
anytime and be ready for whatever
opportunity arises you understand you
could they come in a single little pouch
you put it in your wallet it's all over
let me tell you how easy it is to get
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com you can sell one of the
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online no visits to the
doctor's office no brow beating from the
doctor and Bluetooth tablets are made in
the USA shipped in the discreet package
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to get down
Bluetooth is going to help you try
Bluetooth for free it's free this week
use promo code Joey j-o-e-y and just pay
five dollars for shipping if you don't
not do this there's something wrong with
you because we could all need a little
boost to the helmet bluetooth.com with
Coach Joey for your first month
but first visit bluetooth.com for more
important safety information and again I
want to thank Bluetooth for sponsoring
The Joint I want to thank DraftKings I
want to thank better help I love all you
Savages I want that Tara Mike and the
rest of the [__] crew stay black have
a great weekend and we'll be back Monday
morning Tip Top [__] Magoo I
love you
[Music]
thank you
foreign